herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen des corona virus hat
deutschland verändert im großen wie im
kleinen
diese pandemie und der kampf gegen
dieses virus ist prägt unseren alltag
es verursacht leid herten und kosten für
den einzelnen und für die gesellschaft
und ja seit über einem jahr ist es
notwendig unter abwägung auch unter
unwägbarkeiten tiefgreifende
entscheidungen zu treffen und heute sind
weitere notwendig über jede einzelne
dieser entscheidung muss es in einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft debatten
geben und es muss ein abwägen geben so
wie wir das in den beratungen der
letzten tage jedenfalls die die an den
beratungen teilgenommen haben gemacht
hat manche fragen nun was ist anders als
vor einem jahr hat sich nichts geändert
noch mal die gleichen maßnahmen in der
ersten in der zweiten welle
doch viel hat sich geändert die medizin
die wissenschaft jeder einzelne von uns
weiß heute mehr über dieses virus wie es
sich über trägt was es im körper
anrichtet wir wissen auch besser wir uns
schützen können wir haben unseren
instrumentenkasten beständig erweitert
zwei beispiele
wir haben inzwischen beachtliche test
kapazitäten aufgebaut in den laboren
aber vor allem auch bei den schnelltest
seit der bund den kostenlosen bürger
test übernimmt und eingeführt hat sind
über 15.000 test stellen im ganzen land
entstanden und es werden jeden tag mehr
und auch die impfkampagne hat sich enorm
beschleunigt wir haben neue tages
rekorde gesehen und werden bald weitere
sehen alleine gestern wurden über 500
35.000 menschen geimpft
mittlerweile ist jeder fünfte deutsche
geimpft anfang mai wird es jeder vierte
sein in wenigen wochen jeder dritte herr
bundesminister stellen sich zwischen den
kollegen ich finde die debatte ist schon
lebhaft genug das geht jetzt ohne
helgoland werden gerade über impfstoff
beschaffung geredet und ich finde es gut
wenn sie grundsätzlich über
multilateralismus hier beim impfen reden
aber noch wichtiger finde ich ist wenn
sie in dieser phase für das impfen
werden würden sie persönlich tun das mit
beispiel hat vor dem impfen in dieser
pandemie gewarnt sie können hier noch so
viel über multilaterale fragen und
grundsätzlich keiten in der pandemie
reden wenn sie selbst nicht für das
impfen werden werden sie nicht für den
weg raus aus dieser pandemie und das ist
das problem mit ihrer partei dass sie am
ende nicht genau wissen was sie wollen
und dieser kunden aber impfen und testen
alleine reicht nicht
und die dritte welle zu brechen wir
können das virus nicht weg testen wir
können auch ging eine welle nicht an
impfen
das ist keinem land gelungen übrigens
auch nicht israel oder dem vereinigten
königreich wir müssen also erst diese
dritte welle brechen
und dazu gibt es ein mittel ein
bewährtes erprobtes ein ebenso banales
wie wirksames mittel
das reduzieren von kontakten und damit
von infektionen so schwer es fällt so
leicht wie es sind kontakte reduzieren
hilft denn nur wenn wir anderen begegnen
hat das virus eine chance sich zu
verbreiten
die lage ist das virus lässt sich
übrigens auch nicht weg schreien und
wegleugnen das hilft auch alles
die lage ist ernst sehr ernst
dafür reicht ein kurzer blick auf die
härteste währung in dieser pandemie ein
blick auf die intensivstation die
tagesaktuell sind und die sich auch
nicht irgendwie relativieren dass wir
zählen wieder 5019 sind
intensivpatienten tendenz weiter
steigend bei sinkendem alter der
patienten
wir dürfen nicht vergessen jeder dritte
kurve patient in der klinik nicht nur
auf den intensivstationen jeder dritte
kurve 19 patient in den kliniken stirbt
die lage ist in vielen krankenhäusern
weiter dramatisch patienten müssen
verlegt werden andere behandlungen
verschoben
seit unserer ersten debatte hier im
bundestag war ein ziel jedenfalls für
die mehrheit dieses hauses und für die
bundesregierung immer klar wir wollen
eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems vermeiden eine
überlastung übrigens die viele unserer
nachbarländer schmerzhaft erlebt haben
und ja sie haben wir das grundgesetz
geredet ralph brinkhaus hat darauf
hingewiesen in dem grundgesetz gibt es
auch schutzrechte und verantwortung für
den staat und für uns alle die
gesundheitliche unversehrtheit gehört
dazu wenn sie schon dass grundsätze und
gesetz und diese frage zum maßstab
machen auch in ihren debatten dann
sollten sie auch die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen mitten
in einer pandemie die so viel leid
verursacht
am vergangenen sonntag habe ich die
intensivstation in köln merheim besucht
was professor korrigieren ids und sein
team dort jeden tag leisten
übermenschliche belastungsgrenzen hinweg
das darf uns als gesellschaft nicht
selbstverständlich sein und wir können
ihnen nur dankeschön sagen für das was
im leben tun und wir können ihnen dabei
nur zu sagen dass wir auch ihre
eindringlichen warnungen ernst nehmen
es gibt eine korrelation zu der zahl der
intensivbetten die zahl der
neuinfektionen da gibt es eine
korrelation
einige versuchen immer diese beiden
zahlen voneinander zu trennen aber sie
hängen miteinander zusammen dass eine
folgt logisch dem anderen und wir haben
das doch in den letzten monaten gesehen
nicht nur in deutschland auf der ganzen
welt und deshalb verstehe ich die logik
nicht dass einige immer warten wollen
bis die intensivstation überfüllt sind
bevor sie maßnahmen machen wenn wir leid
vermeiden können sollten wir es
vermeiden rechtzeitig und infektion erst
gar nicht entstehen lassen und genau dem
dient dieses gesetz eine notbremse per
bundesgesetz notbremse heißt übrigens
auch vorher sollte man das bremsen schon
beginnen durch regionale und lokale
maßnahmen
es geht um drei lebensbereiche die
aktuell die infektionen ausmachen der
betrieblichen alltag schon angesprochen
worden mehr herum office mehr test
verpflichtungen weniger mobilität der
alltag in schule und kita
auch dort mit klaren vorgaben für
regelmäßige tests für wechsel unterricht
und betreuung und übrigens bei den 6 bis
20 jährigen sehen wir gerade sehr sehr
viele infektionen und der bereich der
privaten kontakte das sind die drei
bereiche wo wir gerade viele ausbrüche
sehen zwei drittel aller ausbrüche in
deutschland finden im moment im privaten
bereich statt
und deswegen sind kontakt und ausgangs
beschränkungen notwendig es ist schwer
es fällt auch keinem von uns leicht
diese maßnahme die eine sehr stark
einschränkende maßnahme zu machen aber
mit vorübergehenden maximal bis zum 30
juni 2021 begrenzten einschränkungen
wollen wir diese frage in dieser phase
der pandemie adressieren diese
einschränkungen die schwer fallen
die hart sind sind angesichts der lage
angemessen verhältnismäßig und sie sind
im übrigen auch geeignet frau kollegin
ww nahezu allen anderen ländern europas
gesehen haben deswegen der präsident die
kolleginnen und kollegen diese
bundesland bremse ist das ergebnis eines
demokratischen prozesses mit intensiven
beratungen und entsprechenden
anpassungen
es ist übrigens auch der wunsch der
große mehrheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger die sich einheitliche
verlässliche regeln wünschen denen sie
vertrauen können und nun werden wir auch
in diesen schweren hoffentlich letzten
teil des pandemie marathons dann gut
überstehen wenn wir zusammenstehen und
die notwendigen maßnahmen ergreifen test
gestütztes öffnen und vor allem das
impfen geben uns die notwendige
perspektive nach der zu recht viele
fragen aber erst braucht es als brücke
einbrechen dieser welle
dem dient dieses gesetz und daher bitte
ich um ihre zustimmung
[Applaus]